at Georgia Tech interest of time let's
just get into our talks we'll be talking
about algorithm's law and Society thank
you uh thank you so much for having me
here this is such a fantastic Workshop
I'm so delighted to be one of the
speakers here and um
I'm going to be talking about algorithms
law and Society
um this is uh based on joint work with
my fantastic collaborators uh including
my student Chad Salem who's on the
market this year and Devin uh Desai
who's a faculty in law and ethics at
sheller and Vijay
Camry who's a faculty at UIC Business
School
so over the last five years
I've been thinking about I've been
fascinated with algors like fairness and
ethical questions in different domains
and uh here's the kind of questions that
we've been working on uh going from you
know fairness definitions and studying
in Dynamic environments impact of bias
in various applications how do we even
think about or for policy impact
translating domain constraints so that
you have
um uh you try to model as much as
possible uh based on discussions with
domain experts and one thing that I want
to focus on this talk is the changing
legal landscape so a disclaimer I'm not
a lawyer but I'll try to explain as much
as I understand throughout my
interactions uh in this space
so when we think about algorithms
um this typically you know maybe this is
one way of thinking about algorithms you
go from data you have some optimization
algorithm machine learning optimization
whatever Ai and and some decisions on
people are taken and one key question is
what is the effect of these decisions on
human well-being right and we all have
you know thought about this question and
uh thought about it from different
perspectives and
one question that maybe I would like to
highlight in this talk is you know is
this pipeline of data algorithms
decisions legal ethical Fair Equitable
and you can keep adding more uh
adjectives here uh transparent auditable
explainable yada yada and if we modify
it and the next question is maybe uh uh
more actionable uh which is if we
modified our pipeline so that it adhers
to laws Notions of Ethics fairness
would a pipeline even exist like would
we even are we right are we going
towards an impossibility result here or
or do we still have something that's
operational
and knowing what's feasible and can uh
what's feasible or not can then help
guide policy makers and so perhaps our
job as mathematicians statisticians
computer scientists or researchers is to
really help answer this question
so in this talk I'm going to talk about
two different questions one that comes
from hiring and Admissions and in
particular I'd be thinking about resume
screening algorithms and the second
application I'm going to think about is
demand learning so uh the practice of
pricing items as you get more
information about the demand at these
items face
and with both of these I'll try to sort
of get to these questions and discuss
the tensions between what happens in
practice what's legally feasible what
can we develop algorithms for
okay so because the first example this
is hiring in practice in the summer of
2020 Microsoft uh settled with the labor
department for a few million dollars for
alleged discrimination on the basis of
race uh from uh 2015 to 2018.
and soon afterwards there was news that
the labor Department's uh office of
federal compliance uh contracts uh that
has placed Microsoft again under
scrutiny for claims such as these where
they said they would promote more
African-American managers to senior uh
management positions and these claims
seemed very very specific claims and so
they were again put under the scrutiny
by the labor department right that begs
the question you know if a firm does not
potentially look at these what are known
as protected attributes of race age
veteran status pregnancy status Etc they
could be uh suit for discrimination
because of disparities in the actual
outcomes and if they do uh mention these
attributes they're again put under
scrutiny because of disparate treatment
uh impacts right
and um
with this legal backdrop in mind I mean
one of the questions is how do we
operationalize this but let me talk
about the societal aspect of this right
So currently 97 organizations rely on
automatic automated screening methods
and uh this has been studied uh by many
papers in the last few years for
instance uh by Manish raghavan and all
and uh Sanchez monitorial at all and
um
these algorithms are they're sifting
through millions of resumes and so of
course they're automated the machine
learning base there's some optimization
that's happening there right there's
some NLP that's happening there and so
on but we know that there are a lot of
studies that show that evaluation
metrics that potentially algorithms can
learn from uh you know resume data that
we have maybe the GPS maybe the names of
candidates and so on they have their own
structured biases of how these this
evaluation data is generated and so
what's not to say that these algorithms
are already enhancing those biases and
uh uh you know with the wide adoption of
ml so that's a huge problem if you're
using resume screening methods and 97
companies are using these this is a huge
problem it's a huge bottleneck in access
to jobs and on top of that
um just to bring home this message even
more currently 50 of the US Workforce is
skilled through alternate routes they
are what are known as stars uh that's a
term I think what's coined by an NGO
opportunity at work and these are
qualified Workforce in the US but they
don't have traditional four-year degrees
you know maybe they have some diplomas
they have some online degrees and with
the pandemic a lot of education is
already moving online right like people
don't want to pay for classes if they're
not going to be a person and so this is
going to be an even enhanced uh problem
going forward so it's a big problem
societally speaking and so what can we
do about it right so
there have been studies that show you
know fairness through blindness is not
going to work we need to know what the
protected attributes are to ensure that
we can correct those Trends but the use
of protected attributes also seems to be
inviting legal scrutiny so that's not
great
and uh the key question is how should an
organization fix standard representation
in their pipeline uh what are maybe
legally valid practices uh is there a
way to make hiring pipelines fair for
stars so it's not just that I want to
look at a company's
um end game I also want to look at the
qualified Workforce and make sure that
they're treated properly and starts or
other groups that are screened out
systematically and how should laws even
govern algorithmic screening processes
so the legal landscape as much as I
understand it based on my interactions
over the last few years
with people in law
is that most of the laws governed people
and then they started governing
organizations and the laws that govern
algorithms are pretty less understood
and so that's where a lot of the
development is right and so
should laws even govern these
algorithmic uh practices of screening
screening resumes yes soda
I'm impressed but it's 97 I thought
there was like more jobs than job seeks
at the moment
it's like what do you mean by media of
CVS like that must be huge corporations
or do you mean that all the corporations
in the U.S 97 use 97 of the
organizations the U.S use applicant
tracking systems maybe all of them do
not have millions of applicants
yes
four questions
so
here's a way to potentially go forward
right so
uh there's some biases and evaluations
data and one can ask you know can we
model uh the biases so people have tried
to have some models for instance uh you
know there were studies as early as uh
1980s by Claude Steele uh studied
stereotype threats and stereotype biases
where he studied so he was handling
admissions at the University of Michigan
at the time and he looked at what is the
performance on tests of students if
these tests are positioned as testing
tests or if these are positioned as fun
exercises and so people in stereotype
groups often underperform under stress
and uh people who are not in stereotype
trips their performances basically
aren't affected right and and so okay so
there are some studies there in fact a
lot of studies that we see that we saw
in an earlier slide which talks about
this consistent bias based on
nationality gender and so on right and
so the idea was that maybe we know
whether an evaluation is under or
overestimation and a bank nice model by
kleinberg and Robin in 2018 they said
you know hypothetically let's say every
group has some bias Factor so instead of
observing the True Value the true uh
score or the true utility of a candidate
You observe a discounted value So You
observe something that's discounted
consistently for every member in that
group by this Factor beta J and beta G
only depends on the group membership
and they had some nice analysis where
they showed why Rooney Rule might
increase utility and I really like this
paper and this is uh this is a model
that we also observed
for some classification of schools in
New York City where we looked at schools
which have
um a low economic need index and middle
schools that have high economic need
index and we looked at the SAT score
distributions and these distributions
were basically shifted by a factor of
beta which was 0.8 or 1.25 if you look
at the reciprocal right
so we don't see these distributions and
and this model was really nice in the in
the way of you know it's very tractable
you can get some nice algorithmic
insights from this model
so it's very nice but it's a course
approximation every person in that group
is basically given the same bias Factor
you know and how do you define these
groups and uh you know should I have
intersectional groups and people have
then generalized this to multiplicative
models where they've said based on
intersection of every attribute I'm
going to multiply the bias factor and so
on but ultimately you have a group of
people and you're giving all of them the
same treatment right
and so
about the law aspect also this is
basically insulating people from
comparison right and so why is that the
case so it this seems to be insulating
individuals from comparison based on
their group membership because we are
basically saying that you know if
somebody is in a particular group and
they have some discounting Factor beta
that we don't know and there's somebody
else in the other group who has some
discounting factor that we don't know we
basically cannot compare these two
people
and so it's insulating from comparison
because now let's say I have a person
from left-handers who has a 40 score on
their sap and a person from right
handers who has a 90 score on their sad
and we are saying we can't compare these
two right so it's it's insulating from
comparison from a legal perspective also
and so the question is can we do
something more and uh here is what we
proposed
um in 2020
the plus is because
um the journals take forever and
Conference State uh uh whatever so so
it's uh ongoing
um but we propose that you know let's
let's use partially ordered sets to
evaluate people and compare them so
let's be very transparent about where
there is enough uncertainty in the data
that I have for a candidate and given
that uncertainty if I'm not able to
compare two candidates let's just call
them incomparable why do we need to have
uh an ordered list of candidates in
every algorithm why do I need to have
numbers numeric data for different
algorithms why can I not just take
ordinal comparisons right and so
partially audit sets uh go back as early
as 1948 uh uncertainty in optimization
has been considered
even before optimization and control
theory uh as as early as 1955 uh plus
uncertainty in parameters and so this
this idea is very natural in hindsight
and so here's here's what we have so
let's say these are two candidates and
they have a slight difference in their
gpas 3.5 and 3.35 but one of them had a
part-time job who's to say that this
part-time job affected the GPA by 0.15
who's to say what the ability is and at
this point maybe we can say you know we
can't compare these two with certainty
maybe we can take more interviews maybe
we can give them a summer internship
maybe something else but we can't
compare these with uh with certainty
right on the other hand if that guy uh
this person you don't know whether this
is a male or female or non-binary so if
this person had a workx of two years
maybe that person is more preferred by a
company and so at that point I can make
the comparison with certainty
okay now let me do this in two
dimensions of course on every candidate
we hope to have multi-dimensional data
Maybe we have 10 Dimensions maybe we
have 100 Dimensions who knows right in
two Dimensions I could say Hey you know
these are my candidates with the nominal
data the numeric data that I see and I
could ask
maybe these are the two who are top most
in book experience and and GPA and these
should be selected but now
we have some uncertainty we don't know
whether this candidate was actually we
have an accurate GPA estimate whether
some other dimension is accurately
measured or so on measured or not and so
we have some uncertainty sets where the
true data could actually be we just
haven't measured it accurately
and using that if my criteria is that no
overlap of regions on any axis it's only
then that I can compare them then I can
start creating these ordinal models so
that's a poor set right so I can
construct this partial order where I can
say well if candidates
um this pin candidate is definitely
worth solved in these green and then
these two greens cannot be compared
because there's an overlap in the GPA I
don't know which one is better uh
there's no probabilistic assumption yet
you know and and then the the two Blues
are definitely better but now in this
model I can say Hey you know I want to
select the maximal elements uh uh uh
from this comparison and so now this
green candidate also has a chance in the
selection right
and so
this was really nice and I'm going to
talk to you about uh simulations and
some experiments and so on but to me
this is really getting to the missed
opportunities people who are as
qualified but maybe did not have did not
meet that two percent difference in
their evaluation because of their
training or because of the opportunities
or because of the extra job you know
maybe they are the ones who we can now
attract through this just being
transparent about the errors
from an optimization perspective this
definitely has connections to robust
optimization in the sense that robust
optimization is a worse case over
uncertainty it says robust optimization
asks
no matter what uncertainty is uh
realized I want my solution to be
feasible
I'm asking a different question here so
I'm saying give people maybe the best
possible uncertainty that they could
have as possible data could we then
select them
and I'm not even saying that you make a
decision based on this I'm saying you
consider the possibilities based on this
yes Hamsa
the algorithm provides a ranking and
then there's like a human recruiter that
comes and picks people on like observing
people
how are you thinking that they're
responding to uncertainty like maybe you
know like they're saying like no one
gets fired for like taking the IBM or
something like
responsible to seeing that someone has
like a lot of upside that's an excellent
question and something I want to touch
on towards the end of the talk uh so
hamsa's question is do people respond
with uncertainty do they want to hire a
candidate who has so much uncertainty in
their evaluation or do we want do
organizations want to hire candidates
who are very little uncertainty right
and that's that's a very nice question
in fact uh Jack presented this at
Privacy Law Scholars conference and we
had uh lawyers at the conference and had
exact same question they were like is it
is this actually hurting minorities at
the end or is it helping minorities okay
and so I think uh it's a question of
really translating what do I mean by
uncertainty it's not that that person is
uncertain in their performance it's that
I cannot measure that person's
performance accurately yeah that's
that's an excellent point any other
questions
this time
so this is very nice but I was just
wondering if this captures kind of
systematic policies right this is more
about okay maybe there's some we have
less information or less accurate
information right like systematic bias
is an organic state right and correct
this and so does it fix the bias problem
does it fix all the problems that we
have no obviously not sure and we also
want to be careful that you're not
introducing new biases by doing this for
sure and so I think of this as providing
a neighbor to the policy maker you know
they can decide of how much uh
probabilistic way they want to give to a
comparison and and then move from that
right quickly so but my question said
like
um in terms of like fairness I'm just
wondering how are you going to find
fairness based on like if you are going
to ignore the whole kind of systematic
bias aspect and so if they mask the
protective attribute so one aspect of
creating the partial order is to account
for the systematic biases
in the creation of the fashion order so
do that as best as possible
and get this partial order validated by
a third party if you want get it
validated by the auditor if you want and
then run your Android sensors
and in fact you will see how uh
decisions change at your uncertainty
said changes
and so I I think for me this just spawns
up a lot of interesting questions
which are nice to answer from an
optimization perspective but also nice
to answer or make transparent from a
policy perspective
great thanks yes
I was wondering like how are you
planning to randomize over the maximal
elements because like you could argue
for example that oh they're all Maximum
elements so like that's uniformis or you
could say like oh the blue ones you know
they had like more comparisons like
leading up to them so maybe they should
be preferred so that's that's a great
question how do you plan to maximize
over these
I'm going to give you my model to do it
I'm not saying that's the only model
I'll talk about that yes I'm coming to
the algorithmic aspect of it very soon
more questions
all right so
[Music]
this this gets me to the first challenge
I think the the area of ordinal
optimization is underdeveloped and I
think that would be really nice uh to
develop algorithms for this uh one of
the uh you know like an algorithm for
maximizing spanning trees of course we
only care about the order of the
elements so for some problems it's very
natural but even when you go to
matchings it's not very natural how do
you do an ordinal optimization over
those so I think this uh is my first
challenge
and now let me get to an example of how
to do this so how do we construct these
poor sets in some sense I've sort of
pushed the problem of Bio systematic
bias In fairness to the construction of
the post set right how do you do that
and can I even justify that the method
that I used to do that is legally
validatable you know can I stand in a
code and justify uh uh right that that
what I've done in my organization is
fine
and so they're both open questions but
let me show you one way forward
so here is a data set uh this is
aspiring Minds employability outcomes
it's a publicly available data set it
was collected in India and so you see uh
the college tier is a variable here I
don't know if you can see it on the
slide but College tier one tier two
uh terminology in India
um so it's a bucket of colleges that are
all considerative one and then they're
tier two colleges and you see there's
gender there is computer science
mechanical engineering Consciousness
agreeableness extroversion neuroticism
there's some psychological
characteristics people have taken some
tests and they've reported this course
on those they've reported what their
first starting salary was what their
college gpa was what their computer
programming score is and so on right and
so what we did was we said hey you know
let's see let's act as a resume
screening algorithm let's try to predict
the computer programming score maybe
assume they're applying for a tech job
in the in the base data we had
information about male and female uh
candidates for every candidate there was
no binary information non-binary
information so maybe we also need to
expand our data sets but in the in the
actual data uh in the whole data set
there's no skew the performance of
females and males is basically uh
distributed similarly
but when we ran a simple machine
learning model this is just a linear
regression it picked up a slight skew
for males right now this is a media
regression model I could look at the
coefficients I could see the gender had
minus
16.9595 points and so if everything else
is the same agenda was flipped females
would get a minus 16 point score lower
than males okay in this case it was very
easy to figure out why the model where
the model had picked up a skew and so as
a first approximation I could consider
the predicted score and I could do a
plus minus 16 points into that interval
to discount for this fact
but often in practice we don't even have
the machine learning model to play with
maybe we just have a prediction of how
good a candidate is and so we posited
that okay you know maybe we can look at
error distributions based on the group
membership now I know you're thinking
group membership she's using group
membership is that legal we'll get to
that right but let's say I could use the
group membership so then we normalized
error distributions based on the
training data set we said hey you know
we are going to have we're going to add
some Sigma J which is a standard
deviation of the errors that we see on
the training set and that's one way to
go from the the point data to an
interval data for every candidate you
have an interval of where Discord could
lie and you don't even need to know the
machine learning model for this
and now I have an interview uh uh posted
an interval posted as if two intervals
overlap you cannot compare them if
intervals are disjoint you can compare
the two candidates so that naturally
gives us a post set right and that gets
to the mathematical question now can we
actually design algorithms that can work
with such process you know maybe you get
better guarantees or a generic post set
what about ordinal optimization with
that information
so here's
now we are going more into the mat a
little bit away from our society and law
problem but we'll come back to that okay
so the bias secretary problem uh is uh
you know something maybe
basically took this partially ordered
model of Pi espashi ordered set model
bias and we uh said we're going to
consider a streaming model and see say
resumes are coming in and we're going to
do a classical secretary uh optimization
on it so as resumes come in as
individuals come in their post-set
relations are revealed with the
candidates we've seen and then we want
to select
um we want to make irrevocable select or
reject decisions and our competitive
ratio is over any utility that's
consistent with the poor set so whatever
your poor set was the adversary can
assign any numbers that are consistent
with the poor set comparisons and I want
to be competitive with respect to that
already this definition has very nice
properties I get to that and I just want
to briefly highlight the uh
there's been a huge uh literature on
secretary problems but very few papers
that even considered ordinal information
and and this model is is near to the
best of our knowledge
okay so just again as as candidates come
in I only see the Post-it comparisons of
the candidates that have been revealed
to me so far I don't see the entire
process and uh and then I want to make
reject and select decisions and I want
to be competitive with respect to any
worst case uh total uh uh worst case
utility that is consistent with the
person so this is a very nice
theoretical question right you don't
even need to care about fairness to
think about this and uh we spend a lot
of brain Cycles in developing um
algorithms for this
before I get into that let me talk about
some fairness properties right so I
mentioned that I also want to be fair
towards the people who are being
screened and so some consistency
properties that we want are if somebody
is ranked higher that I want a higher
probability of selection not a lower one
at least that much probability of
selection and I should not care about
the order of uh elements so if elements
are
if elements look the same to the poor
set so these two guys look the same to
the process they should receive similar
treatment
so that's that also has connections to
this notion of individual fairness that
people have posited where people who are
similar in characteristics at similar
treatment and so uh we enforce the same
constraint over a percent people that
look similar in the post set must have
similar probabilities of selection
and all we need to do this similarity
thing is just make an algorithm that
depends on only on the arrival order and
the post-head information comparison and
you satisfy that I order isomorphism
property
and for this one we basically want a
good competitive ratio an algorithm that
has a good competitive ratio
needs to satisfy something like this
okay
all right so here's the first hack into
getting a nice secretary uh bias
secretary algorithm uh for the Post-it
setting let's say my post set was just
groups so I had these four groups of
people and I wanted to hire
five people out of these four groups
so what these secretary algorithms do is
that they analyze decisions under
partial information so they don't know
what the pool of candidates is going to
be so they sample the first few elements
so let's say the sample the first few
elements uh from each of these groups
and then we select people from each of
the groups right and the one who beats
the sample in and arrives the first
after the sample is selected if you
wanted to select one candidate right and
so you can do the same thing but these
are setting quotas for every group and
you know that's not legal in many
situations right so we don't want to
just slap on a coda and and call it a
fair hiring
but the nice thing about post sets is
that that that group information is no
longer relevant for a poster right
you've made your comparisons you've
probably used the group information
you've made your comparison so now
you've said that these are the
candidates that are going to compare and
these are the comparisons I'm going to
run with okay so there's no group
information really
and uh
by Design we don't have quotas but we
have something that is known as the
width of the poor set so width of the
Poor Side is the maximal elements in a
post set that are all mutually
incomparable the set of the maximum the
maximum size of elements that is
mutually incomparable and so if your
poor set looks very thin it means you
have a pretty good sense of comparisons
of your candidates if your post set
looks very fat the width is very high
and that means you basically don't know
like out of these five candidates you
don't know who's better and so your
performance obviously goes down and so
this the width uh gives us a lower bound
on the performance of these algorithms
so there is an Omega lower bound Omega
is the width of the poor set that's the
lower bound and the competitive ratio
that you can achieve for uh for this set
okay and so here's here's one example uh
of uh a boosted algorithm and um what it
does is actually uh the reason I'm
highlighting this algorithm because it
does it uses a technique called labels
so as the candidate comes in you assign
them a fake group you send them to a
fake interview committee or you assign
them a label you give them a token and
so as they come in you assign these
candidates to these l124 you want to
hire four candidates you assign them
labels and then within each label you uh
let them observe the candidates so
that's that's again You observe the
sample now when you do this for the
first few candidates
you get an estimate of the width in high
probability of the poor set so we don't
even know the width of the person to
begin right we can get an estimate of
the word so we can estimate the width uh
up to a factor of four with high
probability
and so we can decide at this point if we
need more samples or if we can work with
the samples that we already have and
then every label so every interview
committee then just selects the best
post set best element they've seen the
maximal element the first maximal
element they see with respect to the
sample okay and and so it's a very
natural algorithm it's not optimal
it's really bad uh it's not optimal
there is a two EQ Factor you can improve
it much more we can improve it in the
asymptotic regime when Kate grows uh as
at least as uh
uh log uh
in a particular regime you'll see it in
the next slide uh when K grows fast
enough as n then uh we can get uh an
order of one which is uh
then we can get a tight one but sure we
have a factor of 4E cubed that comes
from the labeling technique the labeling
is not important you can have an
algorithm that potentially does not use
labels but we don't know how to do that
okay except in the asymptotec
so it's a nice algorithm there's some uh
takeaways that are nice from a
managerial aspect where you can just
tell your independent interview
committees to select the best candidate
that you see within each of these
committees based on the comparisons that
they can make
and it has nice competitive performance
so here's the other settings that we
considered so we went crazy over what we
can do with percents and what we can do
with the group model and what what if uh
utilities were stochastic what if
arrivals were uh random or adversarial
and whatnot so these are the competitive
ratios that we have I think the the we
have an Omega lower bound but the other
factors are unnecessary and we don't
know how to close that Gap and that's
the asymptotic regime where we do get a
tight uh order Omega algorithm
all right a lot of open questions what
if uh can you have a privacy sensitive
construction of per sets with all of the
Privacy talks that we've had uh what if
n is unknown uh what if a biased Metroid
secretary uh so you know people uh at
least I know one person in the crowd who
likes uh metroids so so what happens
when you have a biased Metroid secretary
problem the group model is simply a
partition Metroid but maybe you can do
more okay
but so
five minutes
oh no okay so now if if we actually uh
use both set then compared to the
vanilla algorithm when we had a huge gap
in the selection rates so these are gaps
for males and females they had a huge
gap using just the nominal values when
we rank secretary algorithms uh with the
nominal values when we had quotas it
over corrected so the female selection
rate went up much more but with poor
sets it basically reflects what the data
is and so it's really nice because it
directs uh the outcomes of a machine
learning model okay
are these methods legally validatable so
yes uh we have a lot of uh connections
to anti-discrimination laws and here are
some presidents that are useful so for
instance the Johnson B transportation
agency is a lawsuit uh where a man sued
because a woman was uh promoted over him
for a difference of two points
um if the reaching IDI Stephano is a
fire is a lawsuit with firefighters
suing a company for throwing out a test
that did not select enough African
Americans and um
there are some other uh approaches other
cases where we see the courts allowed
Banning approaches which are basically
uncertainty over the intervals which is
confidence intervals kind of approaches
where they're allowed like a two-point
difference should not does not say that
one is more uh capable than the other
and so they should be treated equally
and so on so we see a lot of connections
with anti-discrimination laws which have
been which has been really nice and we
have a lot of view paper that's accepted
on using uncertainty sets and partial
orders for hiring uh settings
how all of this um
goes into practice or not that's uh
that's a good question and so here's an
experiment I did in a workshop at a law
conference it's a global privacy Summit
where I give them our raw scores and I
gave them these uncertainty sets for
every candidate on these dimensions and
they exactly had uh similar concerns of
you know selecting candidates or not
um how all of this applies to college
admissions and school admissions is
another discussion and I'm happy to
discuss that uh with you all offline
I'm quickly going to talk about the
online learning in five minutes
so
demand learning is basically a very
common
um practice there are courses on that
not to pick on Columbia University but
basically the practice of learning what
the demand is for an item and pricing it
and there's been a lot of articles about
why Shoppers hate price changes there's
management science articles about
customers don't like price changes
nevertheless Amazon changes prices every
10 minutes uh a large number of times
and there's been a recent lawsuit where
uh these two uh people McQueen and
billinger sued Amazon uh for price
gouging during the pandemic so the
governor at California declared
emergency and
um
Amazon was simply doing their demand
learning or profit optimization right
based on the demand from their people
and and the increased prices by more
than 400 percent and so that's what the
price gouging laws were uh violated
during an emergency and this laptop on
this lawsuit on Amazon
and so this was interesting because it
got us wondering like is it even
possible to do
um online learning when I cannot change
my decisions arbitrarily like is it even
possible to get to the right prices if I
cannot have non-monotonic movements and
we looked at uh these this is barn and
kesking doing personalized pricing with
genre demand models and so the prices
move all over the place if you look at
UCB prices move all over the place if
you look at
um Hassan and Levy when the prices move
they're very non-monotonic in the
movement maybe they have increased
non-monotonosity going forward
and so the question
um
that we are very excited about is can
you do an online learning with optimal
bounds even when you're
movements are constrained so think about
the online learning it rates over time
and you're constrained on what iterates
you can give based on a decision can you
still have ordered optimal rates and uh
without getting into all of this we
basically consider a monotonic uh
constraint for think about demand
learning and
all of this is generalizable so come and
talk to me after the talk but in let's
say you have students and you have the
general population we want prices for
students decrease over time prices for
the general population decreases over
time and students always pay lower than
the general population
so we have some cross group constraints
and we have uh iterative constraints
over each time and so that's a lot of
constraints to impose on an online
learning setup and um
what I would like to like in this work
what we show is you can actually get no
impact of monotonicity if your Revenue
functions are very nice they're smooth
and strongly convex but if that's not
the case then a parallel result by GLE
and Ravi in 2021 shows that there's
actually a gap if you just have
monotonicity
we also consider group constraints and
I'm going to skip over all this
so we have movements in a constrained
region that's defined by the two
customer segments and we can show how to
do that monotonically by decreasing the
prices and respecting all the
constraints so that you can get an
optimal regret Bound for two groups
and a non-optimal for three groups or
more and that's also something that we
are considering
the last point is that I don't even know
what the future of personalized pricing
is with laws like CCPA would say that
firms should not uh be penalizing
customers based on the data they have
and so I'm going to end here with just
that there's a lot of exciting
algorithmic questions uh that are also
important to answer from a policy
perspective and that are motivated from
a legal perspective thank you
we have time for one question
foreign
thank you for the interesting talk
um I was wondering if you could talk a
little bit more about the poet
construction and if you imagine that
like
um like uh does it like what is the
connection between the post set
construction and statistical uncertainty
like do you imagine that like the size
of the of the process would decrease if
we have more data or is there like some
fundamental like like Gap and also thank
you for the question like I think uh yes
exactly like I think as as you have more
data in a group then your uncertainty
should go down and so one way to
construct Pro sets is to say maybe you
know the level of uncertainties one over
square root n where n is the number of
uh people who are similar to you in a
data set right as bad similarity
increases your uncertainty in terms of
the prediction of the model is also goes
down right and so having like really
quantifying this trade-off of
uncertainty with the amount of data that
you have looking into a small data set
problems what if you'd use like smart on
a small data set like how does that
change I think all of these are very
good questions and they're all open
thank you
hey let's make Swati again
[Applause]
so now we have another break this break
will actually be upstairs on the second
floor uh and followed by a poster
session also in that same space upstairs
in the second floor so if you are a
poster presenter you can use some of
this time to get set up everyone else
comes onto the second floor and stick
around for the posters from four to five
thank you
I'm not just here today